hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay one
thing that I noticed that I wanted to
point out is that this far into the game
at least in cry of fear I started to get
a semblance of the story but I'm
starting to think that there just isn't
a story part of this game so uh but
that's okay
it's rightly terrifying and uh I was
joking and that's all that matters isn't
it
whoops that hurt oh no I only had 600 oh
my goodness oh your heartbeat oh wow
okay this is normal this is normal huh
yeah here almost invisible guy yeah I
see you I see you ah no no no let's
write it down no no no no ah no ah get
you I can get you I can get you with
this ah oh he's got sidestep sidestep
his key
ah damn it I didn't sidestep sometimes
he comes at me so quick I can't even
tell what he's doing come on come on
[ __ ] ah damn it
alright I'm just taking him out with the
gun there we go that's the only gun I
got left
I've only got seven bullets left total
oh not another one
damnit okay I gotta at least try to take
this guy out with the ax because I what
if I come against one of those big guys
it shoots eyeballs that I'd be kind of
screwed okay one more one more one more
one more thumb yes okay I got I could
have gotten the other guy I suppose
okay oh boy yo hop Li ah okay try that
again
oh damn it I'm back here did it kill the
guy yeah I did okay save right here so I
can do by epic leap Oh
so I'll goo I said epic what's up
i what was that I swear sour skull I've
missed this this I need yes please
epic Li oh so great okay got that
woosh push the button alright that did
that I'm sort of curious what was on the
other side of the hallway Boing Boing
Boing Boing boy okay
it's the HEV suit breathing it's so
weird okay
gonna be more I'm gonna go over to the
other side just to make sure I didn't
miss miss out on something oh boy
this is normal was this just bosses
alway all back to this area a code of
ten numbers is it worth it is this part
of the sequence of codes that have been
coming before this okay numbers numbers
numbers ah wow there's a lot of numbers
I remember the codes that were they were
giving me on the other 101 six nothing
else Wow I don't remember it at all
yeah he's one of these is a individual
little button here I even see a zero so
couldn't have been o16
okay obviously I don't know what I'm
doing there if ten numbers is it worth
it I think so why some goodies in there
or a secret ending or I don't know let's
go out here let's get out of here man
all this started in a hospital with this
guy going crazy good boy
hello cages this should be normal okay
yep here we go thank you
oh there's something in that cage all
right
why am I going down okay there we go all
worried about that ah come at me bro
come at me come here come here
just try it just try it epic epic epic
dodges epic Dodge
dammit epic dodge dammit
f epic dodge there we go one down come
on come on come on you [ __ ] come on
you [ __ ] head hands damn it epic
dodge damn it
epic dodge ah damn it
ah epic dodge oh they're still there
come here come at me bro just try it
epic gouge oh holy schnikeys ah damn it
epic epic ow damn it
epic damn it alright that's not working
too well hmm huh okay that's two more
down just these guys resting out hanging
out epic da ah behind me how did it how
did it ah
what where is it how are you there okay
it's got oh [ __ ] ah gah ah I don't know
where it is but it's somewhere and it
can get me from that somewhere where is
it
I'm not seeing it what happens if I go
up here on this one
oh it just jumped at me okay apparently
nothing but is there something over
there that I could get nope cuz that
doesn't work maybe I didn't try hard
enough
ah no I tried I failed alright so go
back and get passed in these assets
oh crap hi epic dodge whoa whoa whoa
whoa epic couch couch ah ah batted this
jump off you ass bag oh whoa whoa jeez
jeez Louise hello okay what are you
doing how you doing buddy how are you
doing come on come on go off here
hey if I can just get you with the X yes
get down
got you alright that was a lot died get
away I don't think so
[ __ ] die get away I don't think
so okay so hang on let me go back let me
do something because this is pretty
important let me make a real save here
just in case those numbers I need to go
back for a secret later if I didn't get
it if you know what the numbers mean
please write in comments below oh boy
die get away lots of die getaways
okay all right
or maybe I oh oh no no no mmm I'm down
come on there we go two down see they do
have variable health or this does
variable damage I don't know which
another one let me see if I can try to
slip by it okay got it
Oh more ammo yes please they still
giving me the right ammo they must have
some sort of mechanic in the game that
picks out the right ammo nope get away
get away get away
oh boy oh oh not you okay yeah you're
shot there we go okay kill that and
those big spider ones are tough okay all
right
far so good for so bad oh come on you
gotta be joking me here goes the health
I just got back
nope that was wrong oh there's a ladder
there how am I supposed to see that oh
whatever
oh not you not you not you [ __ ] okay
swing from the ladder maybe we could
just jump over you there we go
oh yeah that's invisible one I see you I
see you I see you with this - if I can
just sneak past you Nick bass big bass
Nick fast
ah no get up get the lout get a lot get
up that damn the header oh don't know
how I got out of that to be honest
okay I'm okay head hands come on jump
onto the abyss Oh epic dolls coming up
epic epic epic epic haha Oh what the
[ __ ] is this a wall or a wall alright
alright epic Doge damn it
fine I'll just kill you fine fine you
want this what that was a waste of ammo
come on come on come on just get out of
the way just get out of the way get out
of the way let me through
I hate those things but of all the
enemies well maybe the big invisible
ones are worse but nope not today and
there goes all my ammo I could have
taken those guys out with an axe I
should have come on come on come on nope
not today [ __ ] you how do you do 25
health one fit pet nope not today
oh [ __ ] are you and your instant attack
well the other one wants to tango with
me no good
get back no one down come on ah
no no no no no no no no come on no got
ya got ya got ya
all right all right all right
all right the restroom oh my god where
it all began
m12 oh it's another code m12 I should
write that down or something
get some paper down okay gimme gimme get
it and twelve or m12 I don't know which
one it is that bathroom stalls where it
all began
you should have written down the other
now where was that Oh quite recall all
those down there okay ah that's what it
was
way to go for that ah no not
semi-invisible ones come on come on come
here come here [ __ ]
damn it you got stuck okay come on where
are you where are you I see ya I kind of
see ya invisible ass coming here we go
get down boogie woogie boogie Oogie
Oogie ah try it try it
not today get away get away get away get
away
come on hit him [ __ ] me yeah that's
right another one come on come on ready
for you I'm ready oh yeah yeah yeah
you're quick [ __ ] this is just a quick
one I can just take it down actually I
ran out of time I got to take care of
that one in the next episode so thank
you everybody for watching and as always
I will see you in the next part
bye-bye